YEA WSES
LIKE A
JOINING ME THIS  YOU SO MUCH
HAO
>> THANK YOU.
>>- LY
400,000 AMERICANS EVERY DAY.W T
REOI BE A  CASES, ND DEIGAT DO
MON MU, MUCH
LTA
SO EVE
YOU HAVE A THA ACT MIGHT BE LESO
AND FRHE SOME
FROM PRELIMINARY DATFRE ONLY
DIFFICULTY IS THAT WHEN
EVEN IF THETE OF HOSPITALIZ
WITH OMICRONIT THERE DGEG TO HAT
MIGHT ST H
SYSTEM.
SO IT'S KIND OICATED
SUS
BES
SEVE IN IT
THE NEE TOTE AMOUN REQUIREN MIGU
WE CE COMPLACENT IN THESE
H AR
ACCURATE THAT IT I
WE'RE STILL GOING TO GET A LOT
DESCRIBE IS IT
ALREADY SEEINGLMED
FACING STAFF SAG
IN O
N STAND THE  Y KNOW,ISVICES ARR
PARTICULARLY WITH CRITICALS
P SOCIETY FUNCTIONING EADY K TH
1020, 25 AND SOMETIMES OF THE L.
THOMHI
GOING  N BNEABOUT, BECAUSE WE O
WHAT THE CDCDO IS TI THAT DOESN.
O  WHERE,
INT,N PEOPLE ARESYMPE INFECTEDTT
YOU CAN GE B WORK HAE TEN DAY P
WITHOUT SYMPTOMS, THS, THAT GO .
>> SO LET ME ASKBOUTE REXED
GUING UNDE
FIRE FROC
RET OUA TWEE N
"THE LATEST CDELINES WHICH
ALLOO LEAVE ISOLATION
AFTER FIVES WITHOU
OF WHEN THE PUBLICASLDDIDN'T NE
U.S. DIDN'T HAVEYOU'LW D FAUCI.
INESS PRESSURE
EXPLAIN. COUPLE  I DANA,I'
THERE'S NO DOUHAO GE OUTO
WORKPLACE IF THEY ARE WITHOUANIT
NORMALLY BA
SMISSIBILITY IS CONSIDERABLY
LOWER IN THAT SEF OF
FIVE -- OF A AND
FOR TH CDC MADE
THE JUMENTHAT ITLD LOW-RISK TO .
YOU'RE R GET
NCY NOT TEST
PEOPLETH TIME?
I MYSE FEE THAT'S A NG TO
I BELIEVE THAT THE SOON WILLING
CLARIFICATION OF THAT, SIN IOBV
FIVE-DAYHOULD YOU
SHOULD YOU NOT BE TESTING
>> YOUES THE
NO, YE THEY ECAMI
E THE CD GO
AT.
>> SO THE ERWHELMI
>> I HAVBEI ME SAID ,
IN WAY THAT IS SY BEEN IN FAVORD
O GETS
RK. DOING TBEST
IN TRYING TOIGHT OF PEOPLE BAN I
SCIF BASIS.>>OTOKAYS TALKME OF T
CLARITY.
FIRST, DO AT-HOMRA
TEMION?
NSWER IS THEY AN
DANA, IS
THAT RAPID ANTEN TE R BEEN AS N
TEST.
T
GIVEN SEQUENTIAL, SOYOEMIKO OR
PCSITEST, THEY A N
AND WHEN THE FDA CAME OU
LOOKED AY DID INSTACKING UAINSN
HAOMICRON, BUT PSHOULD
GET THE T THOSE STS ARE T .
AY VALUABLE.
THEY'RE VAABEENING IF YOU DO TH
U'
WAS T E WAS SORT OF A SUHE CAT
>> YES, WHEN T SAYTHE E, IFA, T
ARE THEY AS EFFECTIVE AS AN .ATS
RATHER WEAR A COTTON OR SURGHAN
.THIT WAS A CRATION  PEOPLE WER.
EYCTIVENESS AND IF TSK THAT'S AF
QUALITY OFAST TH
USED, THE SUALASKS D OPROTECTIO.
OW SHOULD VACCINATED AND , BUT O
BOOSTED PEOPLE BE? GO INTO A
>> YOU KNOW, WHEN YOU'RE HAVINC
INFECTIO,  ARE SEEG RE VACTED G.
SOHEN YO IU HAVE S
INFECTIONS GOING OUT, T TO SAY T
BETTER DO THEM IG HE PEOPLE AROE
, THSAHI
TO DO IS T  FRIRELATIKNOW AACCI
YOU WANT TO
EXTRA STEP OSA GET
K ANTIGEWILLGIVEN DEGREE
WHAT YOU WAN ARE
PL WHERE YOUAV,
40, 50 PEOPLM YOU O IDEA OF WHER
FAUCI, FROM FLORIDA K
HE SAID MBERS TESTING
POSITIVE FOR A STHSN'T PEOPLE S.
THE REAL CRISIS IS TTIONALR  OR
FOR TE DO YOU SAY TOTEICANS SANG
THINRI
HAS MADEW A MOVE S GETTING PE B
MS AFTER FIVER THAN YS.
SO THAT'EX
DOING .
IF YOUREOMF  YOU WALY GETPLE BA
N GETS CTTHOU T
IMPACT ON Y, THOSE ARE
PEOPLE THAT RETO
UNDERLYI CEN THE HPI DERLY, HAV
C WANT
OP OVER ASYMPTOMATICTIONS, BUT
INFECTIARRT
OF THE PROCESS THAT SPREADS IT
TO THMANY COMMU
WHVE  MANY PEOPLE IHOSPITAL